well welcome everyone to uh Mark Dane's
uh thesis defense and um
it's uh it's always always fun to see
people reach this stage and
I've enjoyed seeing mark wend his way
through the program and
doing his thesis work in Joe Gray's
group and I understand that's going to
continue after this which is good
Mark
has an undergraduate degree in
electrical engineering that he obtained
third over 30 years ago
although he said he thought he might be
the oldest person in the room but he's
not
unfortunately
anyways so we'll follow the usual
procedure where he will give his
presentation and then the public the
audience here can ask questions and then
the audience will be excusing him with
only his committee and then he'll be
excused from his committee and they'll
make the final determination of passing
or not so go ahead
this is picking up okay
thanks
um well good morning and thanks for uh
for coming it's uh been two years plus
uh to uh to get here so I'm really happy
to uh to be here to be able to present
and defend that my thesis it's
developing a computational pipeline for
high throughput quantitative phenotyping
and and what I'll do is explain the
background the motivation for
um the motivation background the
specific aims for the thesis go through
the computational pipeline that I
developed in the data sets associated
with uh developing and and running those
data sets on the pipeline and and then
the major core parts of it the
exploratory data analysis the
normalization and the scoring and and
what wrap up with Lessons Learned next
step and certainly the uh the thank yous
and acknowledgments that for how I've
gotten here
the the motivation I mean for for why I
am here is uh it involves uh things like
the National Cancer Institute estimating
41 lifetime risk of cancer just
staggering numbers one out of seven men
getting prostate one out of eight women
getting breast cancer and so if it
doesn't affect us directly it certainly
affects our our family friends neighbors
co-workers and such and so
um trying to be a part of figuring out
how to to solve that to very high
motivation for me and for the people
that around me and people involved in
the field and one of the things that we
focused on is using cell lines to be
able to
um develop fashion to be able to predict
the responses of cancers and be able to
do our experimentation and and and
that's proven to be very effective
starting about I think it's almost 25
years ago the National Cancer Institute
started developing 60 cell lines cancer
cell lines and mortalized cell lines and
since then they've been involved in
developing or or discovering over 45
anti cancer jobs so it's a proven method
of using the cell lines to be able to
develop anticancer drugs which is which
is ultimately our goal in the gray lab
and and the other part of this is that
cell lines are do recapitulate what
happens in tumors they recapitulate the
subtypes and the features and so that's
very important for us to be able to use
them as effective models
one of the things that we would love to
do this is data from 18 years ago Brian
druker's lab where we've got cell
viability and days up to I believe it's
five days four days and we're looking at
cell lines that are uh that have the
Philadelphia chromosome that causes
chronic myeloid leukemia and we're
looking at cell lines that that either
that have been treated with imatinib or
glivac or untreated and what we see is
that the controls and the untreated
cells continue to proliferate uh while
the treated ones die off and so it
signals like this that lead to beautiful
data like this where 10 years later they
were able to publish that over five
years out that over 90 percent of the
people were event free meaning they did
not have recurrence of the symptoms of
CML when they were taking a matinee and
so these types of signals unfortunately
have been very very difficult to follow
and and are defined again and to track
through and so what we've just found is
that we need to take a more complicated
a more complex view on the uh on this
problem and and so this is a functional
genomics approach where we're perturbing
the cells these cell lines and then
measuring many different aspects of them
and here's an example of some of the
different aspects we're using
immunofluorescent Imaging that we can
tag different different uh molecules
different proteins in the cells and
measure their and quantitative measure
how much they are in individual cells
while we perturb those different
populations
in different ways that lead to Hallmarks
of cancer like apoptosis proliferation
differentiation and so this is this type
of data that we develop on both a
population and a cell level gets very
complex very quickly
and and so
let me step back from that let me uh
talk a little bit about these
perturbations that we expose the cells
to we're using really two major kinds
the first one is uh short interrupting
rnas that that are involved in gene
silencing and they have the ability to
silence uh specific genes within a cell
and then we can look at the phenotype
and a quick run through is the srnas
come into the cell they become part of a
RNA
induced silencing complex and they make
that complex very specific to to to
cleaving mature RNA C
sequences and so these uh the
transcripts and so by by
perturbing by by uh exposing the these
cells to particular RSI rnas we're able
to see the effect of the of silencing
one gene at a time
the other perturbation that we use is is
the by modifying the cell's micro
environment and there's been a lot of
work and discussion about what how cells
affect are affected by their micro
environment and these involve signaling
proteins uh structural protein
scaffolding that that results in the
cells acting different and
differentiating and there's hypotheses
that this microenvironment has a has an
effect on Cell uh drug resistance and
and differentiation and so we want to be
able to expose cells to different
microenvironments in a controlled
fashion and measure those those the
phenotypes
over all of these we also have the
ability to expose to drugs and see and
check for interactions between one or
more drugs within any of these
environments
this kind of work is not has been done
for um for I I for quite several years
for quite a while actually in well
plates and and it's a standardized it's
a well uh Quantified process and and but
it has some and so part of our
motivation though is to miniaturize that
the work in the gray lab is
miniaturizing these into micro rays and
the and part of the motivation of that
is uh both in cost Improvement so with
some some similar ones similar
microarrays have proven to be 15 to 30
times less expensive they're much
smaller they're easier to handle they
don't require uh the kind of dedicated
core facilities that large well-plated
experiments uh aren't require and
um and there's something that that we
can do with with I don't want to say a
small amount we've bought in the
neighborhood of half a million of
specialized equipment dollars of
specialized equipment to be able to
create these microarrays but it's not in
the in the level of the core facilities
these microarrays give us the ability to
do many more experiments to to look at
many more endpoints to be able to to
look at many more perturbations in cell
lines
but that also creates a great deal of
information a great deal of data and
creates the need for the automated
pipeline that's the core of my thesis
project
two more slides on introduction to be
able to introduce some of the artifacts
that go into this data set in order to
be able to make sense to be able to talk
about how we then locate it and remove
it
in manufacturing these microarrays
whether it's the the uh the micro
environment ones or the srnas they take
a similar process that really start here
with these pinheads and here's a blow up
of the pin head four by twelve so we
have 48 pins and we dip them into Master
Library plates that would have whatever
perturbation we want to expose them to
and pin spot them onto plastic arrays
that have been treated now this is a
process that's very similar to cdna
microarrays that were that have been
done in the 90s and and and such and
there's a lot of statistical evaluations
a lot of methodologies that have been
developed that I've used to be able to
do some of the normalization and and
scoring and Analysis in this pipeline
the arrays one of the things at the
printing level it's important to realize
that say one pin can is confined to one
pin grid so all of the in this case 81
spots at this level were made by pin one
and pin two made all of these in pin
three and that becomes important down
the road when we look at normalization
but after after we move on past the
spotting we're now doing things that are
at a global level we flood the the array
with cells they adhere to the spots we
wash them off they stick to the to stick
only to the spots they the cells grow
exposed to whatever perturbation is
there for typically around two days uh
then they're fixed stained and
permeabilized and and then we do the
measurement so these types of activities
cause perturbations technical artifacts
at the global level and we'll see some
of those and the others these pins cost
things at the at this pin grid level
after this stains after the staining the
cells are then imaged and we have two
different types of systems that we image
on the tcan is a very high speed high
throughput system it has three laser
does not have dappy which is significant
to us because adapt is a great way to be
able to locate cells locate their
nucleus the DNA and the nucleus and it's
missing from this machine but these are
the kind of images that we get from the
within a few minutes we get from the
t-can uh on the high content side with
the scan art is a high throughput it's
an automated microscope that does Four
Color Imaging high resolution fully
automated where we can actually make not
only the measurements of dappian and the
other color intensities but we can make
measurements on the cells the morphology
the area the perimeter
um and and get accurate cell counts and
so uh we we the pipeline accepts data
from either one of these but in but we
will also learned is that these types of
things bring in technical artifacts as
well the data that needs to be taken
into account
so my specific games have been to these
three to be able to develop the uh the
pipeline that does the Eda the
normalization the scoring of this data
develop a simulate a method to be able
to simulate these data stats because uh
it helps to be able to optimize and
characterize the pipeline and to develop
it and then to apply that to the
simulated in the action and some actual
data sets and analyze its performance
so stepping into the next um the next
part of the talk the actually exposing
uh talking about the computational
pipeline and uh so I started on this
about 15 months ago and much of this was
very very new to me and and and I would
say that we're looking at a snapshot in
time it is something that will continue
to be developed and and worked on uh but
it's already proven effective in in a
lot of the uh work in the lab over the
last I would say the last nine months
especially
so it has these uh major sections no
bioinformatic project can start without
cleaning data and and this certainly has
to happen we're taking data from the
printer from the either the tcan or the
uh the the scan or and then we're also
taking experimental data those files
need to be merged so that they're all um
in line the data is merged with the
metadata and then from there the
everything the round circles represent
software objects and this this was all
developed in R and so these are our S4
objects and and the advantage of that is
that they're they're structurally very
sound they're there are are bioconductor
packages that that take this format and
do additional operations
the core of this uh is a bioconductor
package called cell hts2 that was
designed for doing well played uh doing
experiments like this that are based on
well plates and and now it's great it
provided background would do things from
start to finish but there's significant
differences in doing microarrays versus
doing the well plates and so part of the
work of that I've done is to bring in
the pin grid arrays into the well plate
type of analysis and to be able to bring
in more work on multiple channels which
the well the the the the cell hts2 had
facilities for that but it wasn't very
well developed and then also at the back
end
our data has uh has many more channels
and so scoring for that is a is a
challenge and so some of the the methods
there I I implemented some methods that
that do a more robust scoring
methodology
so
um that that's the first specific game
and we've and been able to run this I
should I should also speak to the um
the one of the other big goals of this
is not only for it to be extensible by
and by using these uh software objects
and using this the the bioconductor code
it allows me to to build on other
people's work and also to be able to uh
make it modular so that I can I can as I
optimize things I can replace the
different modules but it's also
reproducibilities into you know just a
vital part of of experiments and
computational pipelines like this and
and so at the end these objects uh get
the information get converted into HTML
files into reports the whole scripts get
get connected and and uh and stored and
so it's a relatively straightforward to
be able to go back to the input data and
get the same results and to have have
the process documented all along the way
the second aim is to create these
simulated data sets and this has been an
important function to be able to not
only fully develop and test the pipeline
but to optimize some of the processes
and so what I what the way this process
works is through
the um first of all creating these
sample values that the I'm sorry the
sample value is the end result but the
the base values here are sampled from a
gamma distribution and I chose that
because it does a good job of emulating
the intensities that come from the scan
R and from the the tcan where they start
at zero go forward I have mostly I I've
chose the shaping of it so that it it
emulates it having a large
um grouping of of distribution and then
kind of a long tail which is typical of
what we see in this data
those are then Modified by a factors
that are that represent the pin grid
factors that that that
perturb those that data separately for
each pin grid and so that's where we get
this checkerboard effect where we've
chosen from a uh from a normal
distribution that's centered around one
to be able to make minor modifications
and that can all be modified as well
um from there this a similar effect is
done to be able to create replicates but
here every location gets a sampling from
a from a normal distribution so that
each replicate comes out just a little
bit different from sort of the base
plate the master plate from that and
then at the end I show uh where I do
some spatial perturbations to simulate
some of those global uh perturbations
that we see in actual data sets in
addition to that with the simulated data
set I can create controls and I can
create hits and that's kind of the the
beauty of that it's it's not really
cheating you actually get to create that
and but but it allows to be able to
optimize and and quantify the pipeline
and so here
um it's a little bit hard to see but
there's a series of blue uh lower
intensity that are the the control
values and then the hits and so these
control values I set at a 70 reduction
the hits I set at a 40 reduction and
we'll look to see how well we can find
those after the normalization and
scoring
here's uh here's some sample data sets
that that have come through the process
and then here are the two simulated data
simulated replicate uh that I did the
analysis on and so you can see that in
addition to these sort of global what I
call Global or Regional effects here in
the hot spot here and lower intensity
here hot spots these also show some uh
pin grid where some of these intensities
are are
um are more focused on the Ping grids
and as we started this process and as I
was doing the development we started
seeing pin grid issues in the coming
from the printer and so initially I put
a lot more focus on being able to
normalize at the pin grid level since
then it we uh we take the machine out
bought a new one and our and so and it
looks like the Ping grid issues are are
not as significant but we're still
seeing these these spatial these Global
issues that we associate with things
like staining or washing or South
seeding that's non-uniform so here I've
in addition to the penguins that are
obvious here and this has pingers as
well these uh these pseudo images show a
area of ellipsoidal images at varying
height that's higher intensity and one
at lower intensity and then some linear
perturbation so these can be located
anywhere within a microarray and within
the replicates and so that's part of the
simulation that I've done is to be able
to create different sets to to modify to
emulate what we see coming into the lab
two other data sets
um that uh that I'll do some processing
are an aberration data set here which is
an sirna based data set and and it has
four different channels of um of DNA
this this is uh uh I'm sorry dappy so
this is the amount of DNA in each cell
uh this is these are byproducts of
apoptosis this is a DNA repair and then
um
uh this escapes me and I don't want to
say it wrong but it's another endpoint
marker
and so the the pseudo images that part
of the Eda that's done and and what I've
found in doing these Eda is that you
know most there's not one graph that
shows you everything you want to see you
you kind of get maybe two or three of
the things you'd like to see here the
pseudo images are of the intensities and
so we can see where things are higher or
lower so we can find these of these
these effects based on the regions where
they're at but they don't really show a
good job of intensity because they're
Auto scaled and and if you eliminate the
auto scaling you can get some better
idea of intensity but then you lose the
where the effects are whereas histogram
do a good job of showing the intensities
and how the district how things are
distributed but then you lose you know
where are these peaks in here so you're
really looking at these side by side is
very important and then box plots are
another tool that I'll bring in that
that helps
so the the other data set is kind of
running the other way because this is
this uh has four replicates of one
channel and this channel is a cell count
Channel
um and and these are micro environment
microarrays so here we can see that
there's sort of some funny patterns that
are associated with pin grids in these
rows here and there's some down here and
then there's a column here that has uh
higher intensities than the rest and
that that's receded to seen at some
level through all of these and and that
becomes significant uh as we as we go
through the Eda
yeah grab some water
so a quick summary of these data sets
that are run through the pipeline the uh
the aberration and and I've chosen these
columns because as it turned these are
some of the controlling features that
come into the experiment design so
having randomization is is very
important in these types of experiments
uh and I'll get into some of the
specifics on that the aberration screen
is fully randomized
the uh the Mia data set is not and the
simulated one is we have replicates as
an important feature to be able to uh to
be able to uh
to be able to pull out the biological
signal over the technical noise the
replicates that there are no replicates
in the aberration that we have four in
the Mia and there are two replicates in
the simulation and lastly controls uh
there are no positive controls in the
aberration screen there are no
um controls in the Mia And Then There
are controls and actually simulated hits
in the in the cement in the simulated
data set
so going through the pipeline with these
data sets is what I want to do now with
the Eda the normalizing scoring
one of the things that became obvious to
us as we were working on other data sets
that are similar we had a data set that
had 400 that resulted in almost 400
well-plated pseudo images and we wanted
to analyze that for spatial variations
and and and and pseudo images are great
for showing you where things are but
when you're looking at 400 it's hard to
it's hard to prioritize them and to be
able to know which ones are you know you
should focus and potentially which ones
the experiment may have have issues and
may need to be redone and when I did
some research I didn't find any
quantifications that that did exactly
what we were looking for by finding by
by index or by valuing quantifying the
spatial variation
and so I I developed a method that a
spatial variation index and what this
does is is uh fits a bivariate local
regression to the the data and so there
we've got a basically I think of it as
sort of like a smooth contour map of the
data and what we want to do is we want
to pick up on these regions of spatial
or whether they're pin Grid or or Global
variations but we don't want to pick up
on the on the actual hits or controls
and so these isolated points I call
isolated with the the bivariate local
regression is tuned to be able to ignore
that and then we we use that model
and and measure all of the its
variations from a flat median surface
and then normalize that for the size of
the array and so this results in a
single number that captures how much
variation there is in the array so A
variation an array that only has
isolated points will come up with a very
low value and one with high spatial
variation will have a higher value
some of the initial results that I that
I did on this
we're look look very promising and so it
certainly warrants more work
um and more validation but when we look
at these here these pseudo images are
all scaled the same so you can see that
the variation is getting more and more
intense these these X these uh side
variations and then that is a lip those
ellipsoidal variations as here we're
looking at the spatial variation index
going from zero to point three and then
as the perturbations are normalized to
go from zero to one here we see that as
these variations as the perturbations
increase the variation index tracks
accordingly the same thing for these pin
grits as the pin grid perturbations
increase the spatial variation index
increases along with it
but on the isolated one as the isolated
variations increase the uh the spatial
variant variation index does not so this
is achieving an onset of what I was
hoping for of something that that
captures that variation
the um as we were going through the data
set this Mia data set uh we we needed to
look into why these effects what was the
cause of these effects of these
localized intensities and and lower and
higher values and so one of the first
things I did was was
um
color code the ECM proteins and the
growth factors and the colors don't mean
anything except that I wanted to create
as much contrast within a a color set as
possible made them transparent and then
overlaid them on each other to be able
to see where things were and so the way
these Mia rays are are created is we
it's every possible combination of these
16 ECM factors and of these 24 growth
factors so that creates 384 different
combinations and so this this plate has
has six replicates of 384 combinations
in it and and so here we start to see
that there's something kind of funny
going on and then when I we break apart
the ECM proteins from the growth factor
we see this very structured location of
of growth factors in ecms and so uh what
what we determined was that because
these that these growth factors the
biology and the location were totally
confounded and and that was that became
one of a ver of a series of issues with
this data set that stopped us from
taking it further in analysis so these
we even though we're seeing effects that
are likely associated with the biology
they're also likely associated with the
location and we don't have tools to be
able to to pull those apart
in order to be able to fix that it's not
trivial and this isn't necessarily part
of the pipeline but in doing these
Explorations and finding what the
problems are then it you have to be kind
of part of the solution
um and what we found what in discussing
this is that all of the uh the proteins
were in the were in a row all the growth
factors were in a column
and um and so when and when we do the
pin grid the pin spotting we have eight
pickup points within this master Library
plate so we go here to one and then we
spot go to spot so the the pins only
were able to have access to a small
subset of the perturbations and then the
plate was actually halfway through the
plate was turned Halfway Around
um
and so that's why if I can get back uh
come on I confused it
um
the we see this the the Turning of it
halfway around created the top half to
be similar to the bottom and the left
side to be similar to the right side so
it helps but it's not what we needed to
do what we need to do is if we could
create 10 different Master plates that
have a 384 Master plates then the entire
uh micro array can be completely
randomized uh and we can do that with
sirna it's just the nature of them they
don't have these families like you have
in the mic in the um in the micro
environment in these growth factors and
such but in order to be able to do it
with the the Mia Rays we've developed a
methodology that we haven't implemented
yet but we're kind of working through
and and so it it starts with the uh the
growth factors and and um proteins we're
going to Plate them into 96 well plates
put that onto a machine that can pipe
out individually from anywhere to
anywhere
and then do a mass transfer from 96 well
plates that are fully randomized into
384 well plates
and meanwhile tracking the data what
goes where throughout this whole process
it's not I mean the idea would be that
we put everything that we want to place
we have everything where we want to go
and we can pick from anywhere and go to
anywhere and then we get 100
randomization that's not what this is
going to create and so we need to be
able to be careful and and I want to
simulate this to be able to make sure
that when we're done we do create enough
randomization that we don't have
anything like that structure that we
have before
and so what I'll be doing is going
through that and then feeding back and
and
determining what should happen
throughout this process so that we do
get to randomization once we're actually
at the printed microarray level
one of the other tools that we use in
the design and experiment design are
replicates and the replicates are very
important to be able to increase that
biological signal
and and so the typical way of looking at
the replicates the results is to be able
to plot a one replicate against the
other in a scatter plot the intensities
and the ideal replication would be
everything would be on this diagonal
line
and then we would probably pull do a
Pearson correlation and hope for a very
high correlation
but but in these experiments there's
sort of a
we we're very concerned about the Tails
what's going to go forward in these once
we've got valid data is what is in the
Tails of the distributions and things
like Pearson correlations are dominated
by the majority of the data points which
to us are going to be non-reactive
samples and so there's the tools that
are often used here are not as useful
here but one of the things that the
replication analysis does let us do and
this is the simulated data set it lets
us kind of confirm in another way that
something is going on that looks you
know when things are off the diagonal we
we ought to know why that's happening
and in this case there was a in the
simulated data set there there are
intensities that are much lower in just
one of the replicates and replicate one
and that's why these data points are
pulled off of the diagonal
um and so it's kind of confirming to be
able to see things at this level
the other thing we can do with
replicates is we can do coefficient of
variation calculations and and so that
allows us to be able to see some idea of
how um how how reproducible the biology
is but but I the coefficient of
variation is not a a very stable
statistic in some situations especially
when we get down to a low number of
replicates and so what I wanted to do is
check the null hypothesis of that so I I
created a data set of
um of totally random
uh of totally random results normally
distributed and and pulled but but two
different distributions one with a
standard deviation of
um I'm sorry with a standard deviation
10 and the other with a standard
deviation of 20. and then pulled eight
replicates out of each distribution did
that a thousand times and calculated CVS
on that and so I so there's really no
correlation between any of these and I
just wanted to see what the distribution
of the CVS are what the null hypothesis
would look like and if I were to set a
five percent threshold on that what
would that threshold be and and what you
can see is that the threshold comes out
at different levels and what this is
telling me is that uh that the using CVS
depends on what your data is and what
the distribution of your data is and so
there's not a a hard and fast threshold
that we can use to say yes that's a good
one or no it's not
but the but the coefficient the
replication decision to say that I mean
replicates are still very vital and we
need to have replicates in our in our
experiment to be able to increase the
biological signal
one of the things that comes out of this
is is that it's easy for us physically
to create replicates within a pen grid
but they're not as valuable because
they're that same effect of like we saw
before then they wind up the biology is
confounded with the location
the the sort of the after the Eda one
and one of the things I should say is
that we take this raw uh data object we
do the Eda on it and we
um then pass it through to be able to
normalize it
but but also after we've normalized it
we take a normalized version of that and
do more Eda on it so the Eda is used on
both the raw and the normalized uh data
so part of what we need to do when we're
is is to normalize and normalize there's
a lot of different normalization methods
and we want to choose ones or one that
is effective or that matches the the
technical variations because ultimately
what we're trying to do is separate the
biological signal from the technical
artifacts from the technical variations
technical noise
and so uh what I'm showing here is that
a common way to do that is to Simply
divide by the the plate or the well or
the or the microarray median and that
allows you to compare micro Rays one to
another but it doesn't do anything about
the spatial artifacts the regional event
any of the artifacts it just it just all
centers them at the same location
and and for our type of data at least
what we've been seeing so far we we need
to deal with these spatial these
Regional artifacts and so there are
spatial normalizations that go back to
the one that I that I've used uh the
most has been to go back to that
bivariate local regression that smooth
contour map and use it to be able to do
a normalization of the sample values and
so starting with these two replicates
this one being having pin grid effects
this one having pin grid and these
spatial normalizations applying a pin
grid normalization to it really does a
very good job of of bringing all the pin
grids up to the same level and now the
variations can be compared across the
microarray
but on the one that it that has these
Global effects these are not ping grid
of facts and raising each individual pin
grid doesn't solve that doesn't remove
that technical artifact and in fact one
of the things you can see down here is
is we've actually distorted this data
pretty significantly by forcing
something that was very uniform and low
intensity to have a median that's the
same level as the rest and so that is
one of the you know we talk about
normalizations wiping out or covering
over the the biology that would be an
example of it but by applying this
spatial normalization at a global level
we wind up with with microarrays that
are virtually free of technical
artifacts and and that this should now
be the the signal the biological signal
you can still make out here the effects
of this line
um but for the most part that the the
the technical artifacts have been
removed and and I should say I mean it's
one of the areas that you know we want
to tread lightly and I think of doing
the least amount of normalization as as
we can and to be able to to be able to
do valid comparisons and not want to do
any more because we can make them
perfectly smooth and beautiful data that
has no biology left in it
which would not make it beautiful data
so the the spatial normalization has one
parameter that overrides or is a very
strong parameter that I use to optimize
it for the this process and that's the
NN parameter it's a number of neighbors
it it determines how the the weights the
the spatial parameters spatial
normalization does a weighting of the of
the neighborhood and so you're in
essence determining how far out that
that weighting should be so for instance
if at a value of one it includes
everything equally weighted so it's the
same as a median normalization and at
very very tiny values it basically takes
the uh the data point itself or very
very localized areas around that data
point very few neighbors so part of what
I needed to do was to choose where in
between those two extremes the the
normalization value should be set and
these are partial Rock curves where
we've got sensitivity and specificity uh
and and what you can see see is that
this is another sort of thing that
happens with these data sets is that
there's so many values that are that are
negatives that um that that they
dominate these curves and so it's hard
to get valuable information out of doing
these Rock analysis because everything
is up and to the right because the data
set even by saying everything is a
negative well it you know it mostly is
so you wind up with curves that come up
very far to the right but but what I did
was set the um the end to different
values trying to get a sense of what
might be an optimal value and then using
the the values at different here I'm I'm
using the positive predictive rate and
plotting it against and end values and
picking thresholds this this we have to
be able to get a positive predictive
rate we need to have a threshold that
says everything below this is a is a
positive everything above it is a
negative I think we so to be able to
pick that threshold I use the rock
curves and pick them values that are
closest to the upper left
and then calculated the positive
predictive rate at different and end
values and so this gives me a sense of
where what sort of positive predictive
rates to pick
um and the thing that I liked about the
positive predictive rate or positive
predictive value is that what it's doing
is saying given a Hit List giving what
we call the what the the hits how many
of those are true positives how many are
are false positives and so that's a
really effective tool to be able to give
the biologists down the stream say you
know here's a hit list and I can give
you some ideas that you know is it 10
valid hits and 90 false positives is it
50 50. it's nice to be able to give some
sense of of what the the level of false
positives are
in that hit list
and so
but also in doing any of this kind of
work there's a there's a concern of not
only over normalizing but overfitting to
the data so
um I I picked values that are in this
range to be able to go forward and you
know this is another area that that you
know I may need to come back to as we
get more and more data but I feel like
I've got the tools to be able to pick
these values and to quantify the end
result
um and then applying that to the the
normalization are to these data sets the
aberration data set here's the raw data
and you can see these uh pin blocks and
and and in general there's a trend down
in this one which is because they start
out brighter and they go darker here
we've got this lower intensity higher
and then lower intensity that shows up
in these pin blocks
um I'm sorry uh bot in the pin grid box
plots as going up and then down in these
series of four we go up and down up and
down and so this is actually you know a
way of being able to quantify the the
raw data as well as the same kind of
graphs on the normalized data everything
is is a much tighter distribution and
yet we still have uh information in the
Tails of the distribution and even
though we didn't force the uh the the
each pin block to have a median zero
they all come out with very similar
medians and so to me this is a way of
qualifying or evaluating the
normalization and determining whether
it's kind of gone too far or or whether
it's doing a good job
the other way of doing our quality
assessment is by using the controls and
and so in the simulated data set this is
this is the kind of what this is what we
would love to be able to see in in all
data sets but the result I said I
knocked those controls down by 70
and the um the hits down by 40 and so
after normalization they wind up
controls wind up well to the left and
intensity of the body of the data and
the controls these purple ones in here
are to the left they're still a little
mixed in with the samples and then our
negative controls where there's no
effect are used to be able to determine
what the body uh what the most
non-reactive samples are doing
in the well plate world the a typical
quality assessment is a z prime factor
and what this does is give you a sense
of how separated these two distributions
are of the positive controls and the
negative controls and in there there's
Quantified values Z primes less than
zero mean that it's a low quality uh
plate between zero and a half means it's
a good one between point five and one is
an excellent quality plate but we don't
have these kinds of numbers for
microarrays and in the mic published
microarray for these cells spot in
similar cellular microarrays people have
not I haven't seen anybody publish a z
prime factor even though they typically
come from the same well-plate world so
they talk more about separation so you
know I know there's a challenge there
but we still need to I think there's a
lot of value in carrying controls and
control analysis forward in these
um in these uh microarray experiments
so moving on to the scoring uh we the
the idea of scoring is to be able to
create a prioritized list of hits that
are going to be validated in the next
series of experiments and sometimes
those experiments are not very resource
intensive and sometimes they are so we
have to take that into account as to how
big that list can be can it be a quarter
of the data set can be you know if we
started with four thousand do we want to
winnow it down to a thousand or do we
want to win it down to just a few
hundred so
um that's important to take into account
and and the other thing that I that I in
doing literature search is I came across
the talk of using rank products versus Z
scores and this was very appealing to me
because one of their challenges we have
many different uh many different
channels many different endpoints and
and we have different cell lines the
beauty of the technology of the
miniaturization is that we can create
these these large data sets but then
when we come down to the end we need to
be able to compare them in ways that
make sense and the way that I think of
the the
the Z and ranked products was was uh
proven in some of the analysis to be
able to be a very robust way of of doing
comparisons It's relatively simple to
calculate it's basically you have a list
that are that can come of of uh
perturbations and then you take the you
multiply it's the product of the ranks
across these lists and those follow a
gamma distribution and so we can easily
determine How likely a particular rank
product is for a given experiment and so
that allows us to set thresholds on
things like p-values as opposed to uh to
just quantifying saying you know at a
certain point in the distribution or
it's a repeatable way of of setting a
threshold
so I wanted to do some analysis of in
our situation on the simulated data set
how what the performance of rank
products is and so here we've got again
the positive predictive value versus
list size so this is The Hit List size
that we want to go Downstream and in
this case there were about a hundred and
I think 143 controls and hits that would
that are our true positives and all the
rest are false positives or or you know
are negatives
and and the way to interpret this is
I've got three different levels of
normalization done to the data and then
in blue the results the of doing
z-scoring versus the results in purple
of doing ranked product scoring and what
you can see is
at lower these these this level here is
a is a
is a distribution of the incoming data
that has not been normalized so it's a
very it it's it's not normalized data as
we get higher the distribution gets more
and more normal and and there's actually
a level it's hard to see in this but
there's a blue line that when when the
data has been well normalized when it
comes from a normalized distribution
z-scores perform very well in fact they
they slightly outperform the rank
products but but we're operating in
these range the the ranked products turn
out to be very robust and non-normalized
data and what's Happening Here is we
have two replicates one of them resulted
in a z-score that was very extreme
um and and when we averaged those we
still get a z-score that is that is well
outside the rest of them and that
doesn't happen in ranked products
because there it doesn't try to
determine how far extreme it is it just
orders the list and so I I think it's
turned out to be a very robust method
and and I think it's a way that allows
us to do a little bit less normalization
which is of value to make sure we don't
wipe out biological signal and still get
a robust result here I've picked one
um
uh level of normalization and looked at
the ranked products versus the scoring
and because of the level of the data
coming in here was was pretty normal
um Z Pro Z scores do a a good job
there's one point in the um in the
normalization of that data where the
rank products overcome the z-scores but
uh yeah I still want to do a little bit
more work here to be able to understand
some of the implications But but so far
the takeaway is that the rank products
seem to provide a good job of being
robust predictor
so uh
last uh last few sides we've learned a
lot from applying this this pipeline uh
first about the randomization the
importance of that and uncovering and
looking for that and and we're going to
go to Great expense in order to create
that randomization because it needs to
be there
um trying to be able to do different
normalizations and match the
normalization to the artifacts and so
the Eda really helps by helps us figure
out what the artifacts are and then can
allow us to evaluate the normalization
using replicates in these and some of
the initial data sets that were not
replicates we need to include that in
the design using controls we didn't have
controls and some of the initial data
sets those need to be a part of it to be
able to do this assessment and to
evaluate the normalization one of the
things that I didn't get into is we had
signal to noise issues and and so that
came out through the Eda we tracked that
through to its source and what we found
was that it's really critical and in
this case there was a mismatch between
the dies that were being used and the
excitation of frequencies that were
being that were on the equipment and
that we were measuring it so that that
all needs to be matched really tightly
some of the next steps that I'd like to
do is I I didn't mention but along the
way I had a chance to talk with Terry
speed who developed some of those uh
cdna the spotting mechanisms the
especially the lowest pin grid things
and when I I had a conversation with him
and he had suggested some alternate more
modern ways of doing normalization and
where I wasn't able to complete those uh
as part of the thesis there are things
that I'd like to be able to add to this
and Terry it offer to help with that I
think the scoring on here could really
benefit from doing a clustering approach
uh we're in the process of doing this
analysis at the cell level and so rather
that you know each of these populations
the data I've been working with here
represents a population of maybe 500 to
a thousand cells and we are I should say
you know 52 50 to 200 cells and we have
the ability and we started to do
analysis at the cell level
uh these three all involve the fact that
it's a work in progress and uh so
testing user documentation user training
ultimately I'd love to be able to make
this into a package
um but uh I've got a ways to go and
in Realm
uh boy it's great to be able to be here
at this point
um I want to thank Shannon for all that
over the last two years bringing me to
this point
pushing sometimes pulling many times and
always being there to help me out and
understand how to how to get this far
Laura has been mentoring me in the gray
lab and has been invaluable in helping
me focus on what's right supporting me
when I've slipped and and helping me get
through to actually being a a research
associate starting in a few weeks which
is very exciting to me
Z has been instrumental along with yuha
Nick Wang Jim corcola Spencer and Sophia
is all on the biological side of having
me understand what is going on it's not
my background and I had tons of
questions and so that's been very
important to be able to understand the
biology and all of the staining and
imaging to be able to then bring that
into the pipeline and and Joe has has
been instrumental he's you know for one
created the opportunity but then also
backed up the analysis when it showed
things that caused experiments to be
rerun and that's that's felt good as
well in my life my wife Marty is uh you
know she's the one who's been there all
along the way had to take care of our
kids uh feed me when I didn't have time
to do what was right and
um and so she doesn't get the degree but
she certainly has earned it
and so with that I've left a few minutes
for questions
thanks
talk thanks can you talk a little bit
more about the rank product score does
it give you some sort of statistical P
value you kind of mentioned that but
then you showed the rankings and I was
wondering what happens if you rank a
bunch of things where there is no true
positives do you still wind up with a
top hit list and so then how do you
interpret that you um
so so what we're doing there I mean if
you imagine a list let's say you know
from one to ten we've got five lists
that are all one to ten and and we have
the same perturbation and so if that
perturbation is one on this list and
five and five and set you know two
multiply those numbers together well
when you do that
anytime you it follows a a gamma
distribution where there's a high peak
and then a long tail and we know we can
pick off the dis the uh P values for
that distribution and so uh it allows
you to say How likely is it
given that p-value How likely is it for
a for a perturbation to be at those
particular locations on that on that set
of lists does that
do with those P values well what I want
to do with them when I started
experimenting with this say well what
happens if I set a threshold of 0.02 and
say I'm going to take every perturbation
that has a p-value greater or less than
0.02
so because those are just you know those
are in the tail those are unlikely and
and that becomes my hit list and so you
know when I looked at 0.02 with the
simulated data set it did a great job of
capturing the true positives and not too
many
false negatives a false positive so
you're thinking about doing anything
with like false Discovery rate or
anything like that so you could kind of
scale the amount of false hits in
proportion to you know how many hits
somebody's really looking for or
something like that I think that makes
sense I I you know sort of been waiting
to see well
we have a number of of what's going to
happen in the lab and what the tools are
needed in the lab so you know in a way
I've been kind of waiting to see if
we're going to say
uh how we want to establish and what our
capacity is for the next process
a number of places in your talk Aaron
just brought up one of them and then
with the spatial index and the CV and
the rank product you keep talking about
a threshold
and I wonder if you could comment on
some of the dangers of a threshold in
this type of workflow and in particular
the types of things that would make you
more wary of
giving it
you know members of the lab a firm
threshold to look for
um yeah well I think that's a good point
because I mean calling it a threshold
sounds like it's a defined hard limit
that's really
Discerning what is and what isn't you
know what what should be looked at and
what shouldn't and that's not that it'll
be important as I speak because it's not
how I see things and and setting these
thresholds in a way can it's not
arbitrary but there's many different
ways of setting the thresholds
and of deciding where that of what that
means and so
um
I I think
in I want to be careful about things
like overfit I want to be careful about
um
ranking things as opposed to
caught putting hard lines but I guess in
the end of the day I I want to see well
what is our capacity Downstream for
things like hit lists and try to set a
threshold appropriately so this also
speaks though before the
visualization of the data yes
come on
right
um
one of the the Mia data set is
uh Sophie bornstein's data that she did
using Jim's microenvironment arrays but
I don't know if the it's a different
setup a different layout than exactly
what Jim had oh I see
um so in your high throughput pipeline
this is probably just categorical
nitpicking but you place actually an Eda
uh
piece right yes yes that doesn't really
imply somebody visualizing or looking at
things or Scatter Plots or right because
you know you would do Eda but then
whatever you think that seems useful
you're including your pipeline
so technically a pipeline I mean you
wouldn't say a pipeline has an Eda
component again this is just that it
doesn't change what you're doing at all
okay it's just a naming thing okay so
actually I completely disagree because
Eda is critical in a pipeline and it is
a step in which there is a human
component so the Eda can be generated
automatically but you still need
inspection and it can alter so I think
having an Eda step in a pipeline is
actually fundamental and when it's not
there is where things go wrong
um yeah well I mean that's exactly what
I was asking so if you're actually uh if
this is involving a human
looking at it all the time then actually
that's perfectly fine I didn't realize
that because usually when you say a high
throughput pipeline it just assume that
it's a general running automatically and
not sort of somebody sort of making
decisions but first of all visualizing
something and then going and oh let me
look at something else if such a
component is there actually a human is
involved in making decisions in running
that's fine but usually then it's
probably then I guess it's hard to call
it a high throughput pipeline right it's
um
just a hybrid right so you can still do
things in bulk but there is an
inspection step
and that's not uncommon actually for
many of the pipelines that are out there
now whether or not people choose to look
at that is
you know
an individual decision but it is
actually really common so is that kind
of a philosophical thing where you could
actually have all this in a true High
throughput pipeline where everything is
generated in bulk but philosophically
you're not supposed to look at anything
until you look at the You Know It uh
at the QA and the and the visualization
up front and if it looks fine then you
can look at the other stuff but it
doesn't look fine you should throw that
stuff out without looking at it kind of
like statistical testing right
process the QA could be done sitting
there and then there is an intervention
step where you can continue on or you
could check it you could I'm just
thinking about it
you know if you really were doing this
continuously
getting back
brought this
this if stuff usually works and there's
sort of a flow that you
know if I put is usually kind of but you
can do the whole thing but
Integrity how much
odd to look at the end results and not
the steps because they're sitting there
on the computer
I I would I mean what I've experienced
is I mean we're this is a developing uh
technology and and while it is and until
the results are you know highly
repeatable then the Eda becomes a a very
integral part of the of the pipeline and
and then yeah I understand you know
wanting to jump to the hit list but you
know there's so much information in this
Eda that is actually I put more of my
energy into that than I expected because
of the mature so as you see this being
deployed at least at least initially
it's there this sort of open person in
the loop idea where the Eda is generated
and then they have to do something to
submit the work for the rest of the
pipeline
yes
there's one other thought to that too
which was going to comment on so the the
idea especially for a lot of these
metrics is that you could develop Flags
such that the eda's run and if none of
the flags are shut off then it continues
on but everything is still generated for
inspection if you want whereas if flags
are set it comes to a halt as it should
and then you have the ability to look at
all of those plots and do the inspection
so the real issue is how high throughput
do we get and lose track of the data
which is a real danger as you and there
is an ethical issue there right if we
just keep going through and running all
these analyzes versus really being able
to have the time to make sure that
everything's okay
and uh
and I mean one thing uh sort of I've
done with Jim's data is the similar data
I suppose yeah
if you actually try to uh
right now I mean this is a great
um normalization for doing the spatial
thing but it does everything in a smooth
way it sort of spreads everything right
so but if you actually try to detect
um batch effects like singularly using
something like a surrogate variable
analysis but when our variables are
interested only if they Merit to be so
then um that would be a good comparison
for you to uh definitely too because
some of the big effects may actually
trigger some
you know sort of drastic sort of
normalizations whereas you can leave a
lot of the sort of the other sort of
biologically interesting areas along
that way that's sort of a more of a not
normalizing in a
um you know like across the whole uh
variation but really trying to pick a
few events which may have led to the
dependencies okay it should not be there
it would be a good comparison in your
to-do list I I agree and it's it's one
of my next steps and I started it and I
realized there's not enough time between
when I started and getting here today to
include it so but I but I agree but the
one caveat which is I want to say
because this is being recorded is that
with SVA if you do not know all the
sources of variation or in particular
you're not clear about all the complex
signal you can remove the biology so you
have to use SBA with Extreme Caution
whereas there are other methods where
when you know you have a batch effect
potentially like combat and others they
specifically can model the batch effect
so it's very important it feels like
it's going out into this internet
that people keep that in mind and Jeff
leak and others who you know were behind
that method have made that very clear
that that method really needs to be used
appropriately
but to keep his view I mean Mark has
been really very meticulous about all
sources of variation and this is
actually a very good analysis which
actually allows you to use uh surrogate
variable and out
okay well I think we've got that all
recorded for the record
so I want to uh thank Mark and um now uh
the public will leave and his committee
will stay behind not to be recorded on
the record
thank you
thanks Bill yeah
thanks